mesdames mesdemoiselles et messieurs
bonjour aujourd'hui on va fonctionner
avec plusieurs choses première chose
c'est à pied comme notre deuxième chose
mon ordi pour vous montrer des photos
vous allez comprendre pourquoi et qui
bien évidemment troisième chose le point
le plus important parce que vous l'avez
vu vous avez cliqué dessus vous oui ce
sens le tabouret vous savez de quoi on
parle aujourd'hui on parle du honneur
vaincre ou alors on a déjà parlé
entendez le bruit faut vraiment que je
change de tabourets cherche le croyait
au bout de sa vie on a déjà parlé du
bonheur 20 points on en a déjà parlé
dans le cadre du test jeu direct par un
peu standards les plus performants ce
plus globale et là on se concentre
vraiment sur la partie photo vidéo j'ai
attendu un peu et stendhal faire plein
de photos jettent à chamonix la semaine
dernière et je savais que le spot à
l'aide d'un gang et qu'on allait sortir
plein de beaux clichés dont je suis très
content d'avoir pu tester ce smartphone
point du photos vidéos en ayant pris un
petit peu le temps et devant après ceux
donnés il ya des trucs vraiment superbe
avec ces honneurs 20 projets du tout
vous détaille notre époux instant et les
trucs qui sont un petit plat en mode
waouh on impressionne il ya un peu du
what the fuck très très peu mais
globalement l'expérience est incroyable
donc ce qu'on fait c'est que on va
reprendre un peu le côté technique pour
revoir pas si vous le savez on oublie un
peu la fiche technique peau n'est pas là
pour apprendre par coeur puis entre vous
et moi et puis technique apprendre par
coeur ça sert à rien et c'est un petit
peu chiant donc on va regarder ce que ça
dit d'un point de vue technique ce qu'on
a à l'intérieur et surtout on valide
droite au but
je vais vous montrer les photos que j'ai
fait vous avez déjà le sportif est
vraiment incroyable
et puis surtout vous allez voir cette
petite bête là pour faire des photos si
vous voulez un photophore photophone un
bon photophone déjà vous avez une très
bonne machine un excellent rapport
qualité/prix très beau travail de la
part due aux normes son nom est déjà
prêt dans la passante vidéo et vous
allez voir en photo franchement bien
loin du stac aussi
[Musique]
pour le disais je suis très clair je me
perds transparent les specs
on n'est pas là pour les apprendre par
coeur ça le sert strictement à rien de
connaître des spectateurs c'est comme
quand j'étais étudiant à sarnia rien
d'apprendre les cours parker fallait
savoir s'en souvenir être malin et c'est
la même chose pour l'estac
alors on va se refaire hyper ça je vous
faire un gros focus en gros plan là
dessus vous allez revoir et le truc est
hyper cool un premier objectif principal
c'est 48 mégapixels à sony et 1586 jeu
déjà parlé c'est la dernière caméra très
haut de gamme de sony ce pour les
smartphones qui d'ouverture en plus la
de f 1.4 de très bonnes stabilisation
optique électronique donc ça c'est
vachement cool c'est bien sur quatre
axes pour l'optique donc vraiment
vraiment bien vous avez une deuxième
caméra 16 mégapixels ouverture à être
2.2 c'est une carrière très grand-angle
avec un angle de 117 degrés donc ça
aussi c'est super cool et puis vous avez
une troisième caméra c'est un 8
mégapixels c'est un téléobjectif qui
ouvre avec 2.4 stabilisation optique
zoom optique x 3 x 5 hybride x 30
numérique donc assez cool et là vous
avez toute petite caméra cachée là c'est
2 mégapixels macro f 2.4 pour
l'ouverture pour vous mettre à quatre
centimètres fort des photos complètement
optimisé et si elle avance vers une
caméra de 30 2 mégapixels qui est
planqué dans le poisson juste là ici est
ce qu'on la voit nue comme ça et elle
ouvre à f 2.0
on en plus de ça un autofocus laser pour
faire un point extrêmement rapidement
ont pu bien évidemment faire de la vidéo
jusqu'en 4k à 30 images par seconde
vidéo qui est stabilisé et on a un score
sur dix ex marque 211
autant dire que on est quand même plutôt
pas mal pour notre test il ya quelques
points qui sont essentiels première
chose qu'on va regarder c'est tout ce
qui va être un petit peu standard
j'écris extrêmement mal ensuite on va
regarder la partie
zoom à savoir qu'on est effectivement un
x 3 optique pendant 1 fois 5 hybride et
on a 1 x 30 on va en tout cas jusqu'au x
30 ans numérique
ensuite on va regarder la partie
grand-angle je sais j'écris extrêmement
mal ensuite on va regarder bien
évidemment la crau on va regarder
ensuite la photo de nuit ça c'est hyper
important parce que cela et c'est
quelque chose qu'on met de plus en plus
en avant et pour comparer par rapport à
la concurrence ce qui se fait
on va regarder bien évidemment le sel
fille avec la caméra 30 2 mégapixels on
va regarder bien évidemment le mode
portrait voilà et on va regarder ce qui
se passe du côté de la vidéo même si
c'est quand même aujourd'hui beaucoup
plus accessoire comme ça vous avez la
trame pour venir faire vos tests de
photos vidéos pour smartphones on a des
les points essentiels
je vous fais un tour très rapide de
l'interface bon je pense que vous devez
connaître quatre habitués il ya indien
dingue mot d'ouverture clichés nocturne
ici mode portrait photo vidéo plus et là
vous avez pas mal de petites choses
ce qu'il faut retenir surtout je dirais
six centimètres super macro si vous
voulez faire la macro d'activer le mode
hdr ici si vous voulez activer
désactiver fabra je vous montre les
photos directement sur mon mac tout
simplement parce qu'on se rend mieux
compte sur un écran d'ordinateur que sur
l'écran smartphone pour vraiment voir la
qualité
j'ai connu sur la caméra de 40 8
mégapixels sur la caméra principale il
ya une vraie belle qualité ce qui est
très intéressant c'est la restitution
vous avez des zones qui sont un peu plus
sombre ici et j'ai fait exprès de
prendre un contre joué avec le soleil en
face qui est pourtant voyez on a bien le
détail au niveau des nuages on n'a rien
de cramer on voit bien les cimes des
montagnes on a des couleurs qui sont
assez justes alors bien évidemment donc
là soyez donc tout de suite ce n'est pas
idéal idéal mais voyez on a bien un bloc
plus forts symboles un peu plus clair
que vous avez votre verre ici qui est
juste vous voyez bien vos lumières vos
lampes ici directement ici dans
l'éclairage on voit bien la façade
donc on a un vrai beau détailla vrai
beau travail qui est fait on voit bien
même les marques qui sont situées juste
là et on pourrait presque faire les
plaques ce qui n'est pas l'intérêt si
mais voyez on a des jeunes sont un peu
plus foncée mais on devine tout très
bien pour voir qu'on est à contre jour
et c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
assez juste
d'une façon globale qu'on va voir sur
son smartphone c'est que la photo prise
sur la le capteur principal à 40 8
mégapixels marche merveilleusement bien
et on va dire tout le détail si au
niveau de la forêt on n'est pas sûr
saturé c'est très juste les couleurs
sont vraiment très juste et ça j'aime
beaucoup pareil avec le ciel la voyez le
soleil ici ça marche bien ici on a quand
même toute une partie qui est qu on voit
bien qu'on devine bien pour voir qu'on
aime être sur les lèvres donc les choses
sont quand même extrêmement juste les
petits parapente dans le ciel ça marche
on les voit bien en face vous avez le
mont blanc avec le glacier de belles
qualités de couleurs très jusqu'alors
très naturel pas du tout sûr saturé donc
ça je me sens vraiment vraiment très
très bien briller la terre est pas
complètement marronner foncé on n'a pas
un verre qui est hyper pétant lundi
kodak sont extrêmement naturel
extrêmement préserver ça c'est vraiment
cool
le bleu l'a vraiment chouette quelque
chose qui est vraiment beau très juste
et vas y c'est tout ce boulot qui est
fait et qui est vraiment très
impressionnant qui fait sur cette caméra
flip l'on va commencer à aller dans la
progression
donc là on a la photo principale clé
capteurs 48 mégapixels ça marche
parfaitement bien on va avancer
là on a le zoom optique x 3 par fait
pareil
très bonne maîtrise on est dans la même
gamme de couleurs de ce combat à bord
par rapport au capteur principal donc
c'est pareil ça marche bien une belle
maîtrise est vraiment très très juste on
va avancer ensuite avec le zoom x 5
hybride ça fonctionne là j'ai mille
grand-angle et je trouve que on retrouve
à peu près les mêmes couleurs si on
avoir par rapport à la photo up à cette
photo là regardez là la couleur de la
prairie et la couleur de la montagne
c'est pas exactement le même capteur
mais ça reste quand même assez justes
alors après c'est un peu plus mon lyon
on a une moins bonne définition on n'est
pas sur une même qualité au niveau de la
caméra ne trouve que malgré tout ça fait
quand même le taf et l'a ensuite on
arrive à les pousser au maximum le zoom
là on est sur le x 30 numérique
alors il ya le côté what the fuck de ce
qu'on peut aller chercher c'est vraiment
côté de gaja comme se retrouver sur
d'autres smartphones qui font ce genre
de zoom pour elles voire très loin par
contre est toujours très impressionnant
c'est qu'est-ce que vous allez prendre
vos smartphones est allé chercher bien
fille est extrêmement stabiliser l'image
ne bouge pas il ya un vrai beau travail
qui fait de ce point de vue là en tout
cas de point de vue logiciel lorsque
vous allez chuté mais rendu derrière
n'est pas exceptionnel pareil capteur
principal zoom x 3 c'est cool ça marche
bien voir classé très blanc on voit
quand même ici on devine donc c'est bien
c'est pas cramé c'est juste on va
ensuite x 5
on a les glaciers le mont blanc ça
marche le tri grand-angle ça fonctionne
même la radio niveau du ciel pour qu'il
n'y a rien de cramer ça c'est juste
peut-être légèrement ici mais on a le
soleil s'est pas surprenant et là on
arrive directement avec le x 30
alors ya les fameux what the fuck il ya
effectivement on est dans la montagne on
est dans la neige mais bon ça rajoute
quand même quelque chose qui est pas
terrible qui entre lycées avec du bruit
je ne sais pas j'ai à mon pote le
nounours qui fait du parapente ça ça m'a
fait sans ça on met bien évidemment
ultra grand angle ça marche parfaitement
bien là on est sur la caméra de celle
fille alors besoin bien que je trouve
que cette caméra elle marche bien elle a
qu'a un rendu qui est naturel qui
fonctionne bien vous soyez à contre jour
même si c'est tout de suite un petit peu
plus après si on est un peu moins bon on
est le ciel qui est un peu plus cramer
ici mais bon les sur une terrasse elle
fit donc on va pas non plus
demander la lune comme soit 48
mégapixels ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal
dans l'absolu sous tous les angles
voulait dès lors vous avez le soleil en
face c'est bien alors là j'ai le fro un
petit peu cramé un peu sur aix bon voilà
c'est pas parfait mais ça fonctionne
bien on se retrouve sur la caméra
normale avec un héros principal
zoom x 3 vous avez bien glacier le mont
blanc c'est très sympa zoom x 5
on a quand même tout le détail du
glacier donc ça c'est cool le très grand
temps que ça marche
et là paf on met le x 30 tout de suite
voyez on a les mêmes travers les malgré
tout on peut aller chercher donc à cames
un peu l'effet waouh donc ça c'est
plutôt cool il soit + photo normale x 3
c'est juste avec leur mariage est très
juste fois cinq ans dans les mêmes temps
dont il ya vraiment ravi personnage qui
fait là c'est vraiment chaud on continue
caméra principale caméra principale sa
marque dont il y avait de l'orage
dépendant l'utmb
c'est un peu la galère à la tombée de la
nuit mais ça fonctionne c'est très juste
couleurs très naturel alors là on arrive
dans les photos ne lui alors là ça c'est
intéressant
le côté photo nuit parce que c'est bien
et pas bien fait pas ou fait mais ça
fonctionne la gelée prise caméra à la
main il y avait une source lumineuse sur
le côté c'est pour ça que vous allez
tous tester un peu un peu flammes et qui
vient petit peu cramé un peu le truc
bon ce qu'on voit tout de suite que ça
rajoute quand même beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de bruit ça c'est une
évidence pour moi pour faire la photo
nue là dessus il faut pas bouger le posé
sur un trépied
si vous voulez avoir rendu si vous tenez
à la main ne bougez pas moi qui tremble
c'est pas terrible à une fois qu'elle a
été posée voyez on se retrouve avec un
du bruit dans le ciel c'est une évidence
parce qu'ils craignent une montée en iso
pour venir à compenser mais je voyais
pas ça moi avec mes yeux donc c'est
quand même cool que ça revient à sortir
enfin des signes très très bien le
contour de la montagne là je le tenais à
la main sans résultat qui est correct
bon alors il y avait les serrages public
donc ça fonctionne mais c'est pas mal et
l'a posée par terre voyez on à
l'éclairage la public nous écrire ça
c'est pas éclairé mais malgré tout ça
devient vraiment compensé le manque de
lumière qu'on avait en eau sur la partie
ici tout en sachant qu'on avait les
cadrages ici en bas donc c'est ça semble
très très juste parce qu'on a quand même
envoyé entre les petits brindille
derrière mais le détail de la montagne
et jusqu'aux étoiles et donne une belle
compensation donc là où on voit toute la
force de frappe et la puissance logiciel
donc ca ca section la photo tout nuit
c'est plus au même moment en face à tout
ça il faut savoir l'aja tient la main
volé et beck vous bouger un petit peu
tout de suite ça devient apprécié sa
rage et du bruit
bon on y sort de la photo de nuit ça me
paraît pas c'est anormal
tout de suite voyez lorsque j'allais
faire des photos ennuyer bien ça marche
bien il ya du bruit mais ça marche j'ai
enlevé sur le lendemain matin
ça fonctionne toujours rock hypothèse
vous le conseille aux houches punch à
monique est vachement cool on va les
faire le gym x 3 le zoom x 5 jeux très
grand-angle et là on va les sphères
l'aiguillé du midi qui est juste en haut
ici sait pas s'il voyait bien alors on y
va
photo principale normal on continue à
avancer on a toujours les détails dans
les nuages
on voit bien la montagne ici un bout de
soleil derrière mais malgré tout on a
bien détail en dessous de la montagne
c'est bien une belle compensation pour
continuer on arrive au zoom x 5 x 5 vous
avez le le téléphérique qui montrent
juste là sur le côté et attention pas on
arrive au point 30
alors c'est complètement on peut en rien
à faire franchement mais c'est quand
même cool de pouvoir voir ça on voit
bien les nuits du midi on voit le téf
eric son côté si apprécié mais celle là
et c'est que non marié sur le mode
portrait je trouve que ça fonctionne pas
mal ya un côté légèrement flouté
légèrement lycée l'a1 envoyer des poils
sur le bout des doigts sont juste là et
bien là ils ont disparu comme si j'avais
une belle épilation nokia côté le
lissage quand même c'est pas
complètement parfait mais ça fonctionne
ce deuxième essai comme toujours ici
voyez on devine légèrement plus mais bon
voilà ça fonctionne pas venir nous met
dedans c'est pas le mode portrait qu'il
avoue mettre par terre
mais petit ça fonctionne quand même
plutôt pas mal bon la macro fonctionne
je trouve pas ça terrible moi je trouve
qu'il ya un côté un peu lisse et qui est
pas terrible au niveau du traitement en
plus je poussais sursaturé par rapport à
ce que vous avez dans la réalité
bon voilà on peut le faire pourquoi pas
mais le rendu quand même voyez là c'est
pas juste du tout là je trouve ça
vraiment pas terrible le détail qui fait
d'un point du traitement logiciel
bon c'est pas d'un goût d'un côté de ça
est ce que vous allez vraiment cherché à
faire de la mecque rôle des smartphones
voilà je suis pas sûr après il faut
vraiment savoir combien capteur de 2
mégapixels donc on va pas non plus lui
demander la lune là dessus c'est parce
que j'aimais me chercher ma maman
l'écriture et j'écris quand elle relate
journal on peut venir s'approcher un
petit peu on peut pas faire la vraie
grosse macro elle est vraiment très très
près donc un côté un peu macro mais
c'est pas la réelle maquereau et le
rendu n'est pas satisfaisant je vous ai
pris quelques vidéos qui était pris
pareille à l'utmb l'ultra trail du mont
blanc avec les coureurs qui sont au bout
de leur vie donc les pauvres ils ont
pouvait plus appuyer quelques jours
alors
je trouve que c'est correct on n'est pas
sur un truc de fou au niveau de la vidéo
je trouve qu'une fois de plus les
couleurs sont très justes voyez là
julien zoomer dézoomer tout de suite ça
bouge c'est un peu moins bon quand on
peste exercice là ça ne paraît pas
anormale mais voyez je viens plus ou
moins là tout de suite je me force à
nous ramène un bruit qui est vraiment
horrible la qualité est pas terrible là
dessus bon c'est pas anormal ce qui est
bien ce que vous aller filmer ce qu'ils
cherchaient pas à zoomer ne cherche et
réclame non pas à jouer mais là je fais
une vidéo de nuit
alors c'est pas du tout fait pour la
vidéo de nuit on le voit tout de suite
c'est très imprécis ça rajoute beaucoup
de bruit c'est pas fait pour ça dès
qu'on bouge tout un espèce de ce
phénomène un peu de mouvement
bon en terme de vidéo il n'est pas la
même hauteur que ce qu'il va proposer en
tout cas en terme de photos est ce que
j'aime bien ça la stabilisation on a des
motos qui est vraiment hyper stabiliser
ces smooth y croient qu'avec moi
franchement ils en feront donc ça ça va
c'est plutôt bien en vidéo il est pas
mal nous permettra de filmer à faire
quelques souvenirs mais clairement vous
n'allez pas l'acheter pour aller faire
la vidéo pas du tout bon résultat final
un résultat global on va faire l'état
on va regarder les autres alors ça c'est
très important parti un petit peu
standards qu'on a vu tout en haut et bas
pour voir la caméra de 48 mégapixels
elle fonctionne merveilleusement bien
très belle maîtrise au niveau du capteur
sony avec folié nexus 586 qui marchent
vachement bien
j'ai fait d'avoir une ouverture à f 1.4
c'est cool ça s'éliminer on a vraiment
quelque chose qui marche parfaitement
bien donc ça pour moi c'est extrêmement
valider tout ce qui est standard c'est
top
on y va le zoom x 3 par aig de zoom x 3
regarder of je vous le mets dans de mire
allez on va faire ça comme ça
le zoom x 3 moi c'est pareil je lui mets
une excellente note parce que je trouve
vraiment cools une phase avec je trouve
vraiment cool par contre le zoom x 30
non c'est what the fuck
c'est un peu marrant il ya un truc un
peu rigolo au fait d'aller chercher mais
en terme de qualité on n'y est pas mais
c'est pas uniquement propre à ce
téléphone tous les smartphones que vous
proposez des zooms au delà du x 10 on
n'y est pas c'est what the fuck c'est
bien ça permet d'en parler et de montrer
tous cas on recherche et développement
derrière mais c'est pas ouf
le grand angle c'est pas mal allez on va
dire de l'à-peu-près c'est plutôt bien
ça permet effectivement d'avoir quelque
chose qui est cool mais c'est pas ouf
la macro pour moi allez on va se dire
pas terrible faux-pas south la photo de
nuit
alors ça dépend vraiment de ce que vous
allez prendre si vous la stabiliser si
vous la poser bien sûr en paix c'est pas
mal on va se dire aller
on va dire à peu près moyens la caméra
de celle fille elle n'est pas folle elle
fait le job pareil moyens le mode
portrait c'est sensiblement la même
chose
la vidéo pour moi c'est pas fait pour
c'est pas terrible et par contre ce qui
est vraiment géniale du coup sur ce
smartphone si on se fait un petit peu un
compte rendu global la caméra 48
milliard excellent merveilleuse zoom x 3
ou france 5 tout ça est très bien
étalonné vous en trouve vraiment
homogène où ça joue ça vraiment cool
leaf est grand plus cool pour certaines
photos à utiliser bien évidemment si
vous avez beaucoup de lumière c'est ce
qui marche le mieux la faute aux nuits
ça peut fonctionner si vous le posez sur
enter dans des conditions vraiment
qu'ils sont très spécial après est-ce
que vous êtes là pour faire des photos
de nuit avec un smartphone je suis pas
sûr je suis vraiment pas sûr caméra
selphy fonctionne à peu près nous on a
pour moi un smartphone qui est vraiment
cool et qui surtout tient les promesses
les plus importantes à dire faire des
photos de bonne qualité
lorsque vous avez suffisamment de
lumière comme ça c'est vraiment cool
pour moi en tout cas ceux au nord 20 pro
tient ses promesses
clairement il tient ses promesses pour
moi c'est une très belle proposition
café au nord cette année
ce combo magique avec ces quelques
capteurs fonctionnent on aurait pu
peut-être allez en avoir que trois le
quatrième un petit peu ou à la boîte de
fuck
mais il est là exit donc bon absolue
pourquoi pas vous mais les amateurs ce
que vous en pensez en bas en bas juste
en dessous vous savez le petit
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
est-ce que vous pourrez vous laisser
tenter par ces honneurs d'un pro est-ce
qu'il vous de bottes qu'est ce que vous
pensez de ces caméras quel visage vous
avez vous avec votre smartphone pour
l'ajouter est ce que vous allez faire de
la photo de nuit parce que c'est un truc
kitsch et vous parle
oui non quoi comment vous marrer tout ça
remarque vous allez question
interrogations suggestions pouvez y
aller voilà ce fut un gros bisou grand
mec est jeune rendez vous dès demain
ciao